kleines stückchen amerika für die kinder
damit der abschied nicht so schwer fällt
erst einen monat ist familie karte in
münchen
nach 13 jahren in den usa und gucke ich
gestern gemacht
sie hätten nicht zurück müssen beide
sind hoch qualifizierte fachkräfte haben
als expertin und investmentmanager sehr
gut verdient dennoch wollten sie wieder
nach deutschland
dass unsere kinder in deutschland groß
werden so wie wir in deutschland groß
geworden sind
wir wollen dass hierdurch die schule
gehen wollen dass sie ihre großeltern
kennen das sie zu der familie mehr dazu
gehören es war halt an der us westküste
immer ein großer abstand und ein
riesiger aufwand mal her zu kommen
beim finden der richtigen kita an sie
hilfe
return to bavaria ein staatliches
vermittlungsbüro unterstützt kostenlos
rückkehrwillige wie die kasse
die agentur hat ihnen bei der
schwierigen suche nach einer unterkunft
in münchen geholfen
2200 euro kostet das haus im monat
günstig für die stadt die cafés haben
sofort zugegriffen und sind überrascht
ist es denn völlig anders als in den usa
selbst bei einem neuen hausmann wert
angekommen und hätten im kühlschrank der
läuft schon dann kann man einfach seine
sachen stellen hier müssen wir es bei
kühlschrank kaufen und wirklich
wo sie wohnen wissen die cajas jetzt was
fehlt ist ein maßgeschneiderter
arbeitsplatz das kann schon mal dauern
was zu suchen so wie man das in amerika
kennt übers internet und dann vielleicht
mit einem headhunter und dann über das
telefon
so funktioniert es hier gar nicht hier
muss man erst mal hingehen interviews
führen möchte man möchte also immer
dieses persönliche bei deutschen
arbeitgebern haben und da muss ich sagen
hilft die return to bavaria unheimlich
weil die einen dann sozusagen schon mal
vor selektierte liste von arbeitgebern
hinstellen die bereit sind ein sozusagen
zu interviewen und dann auch schon das
gespräch vermitteln
manche und holger karg können sich bei
der suche nach einem deutschen
arbeitgeber immerhin zeit lassen denn
sie arbeiten vorerst aus münchen für
ihre amerikanischen firmen im büro von
return to bavaria geht die suche nach
deutschen fachkräften im ausland
ungebrochen weiter
getan wer was kann ist willkommen
besonderes interesse erleben seitens der
mittelständischen unternehmen die eben
interessiert sind an ingenieuren die
interessiert sind an bio
wissenschaftlern an
naturwissenschaftlern aber auch
unternehmen die sich besonders
internationale profile wünschen
und davon haben wir einige in bayern die
direkt an unsere zielgruppe stark
interessiert sind
eines dieser unternehmen ist rohde &
schwarz
der high tech konzern baut nachrichten
und messtechnik ein arbeitsfeld für
spezialisten
die sind schwer zu bekommen wir
beobachten sehr genau die entwicklung
der elektro studenten elektrotechnik
studenten und da werden wir noch zwei
drei jahre ein gutes potenzial haben
aber danach sehen wir einen deutlichen
abfall und das ist eigentlich die
herausforderung von der vor der wir
stehen
und deswegen ist auch personalchef hans
knappik an rückkehrwilligen deutschen
experten interessiert
leuten wie den cajas die müssen sich
jetzt erst einmal in der alten aber
irgendwie doch sehr neuen heimat
einlegen
es braucht schon ein paar jahre das so
richtig einmal ist jetzt ist es
abenteuer und aufregung und alles ganz
neu und alles ganz toll aber ihre heimat
dazu sagen da muss man glaube ich den
bayern noch mal waren